all right here we are let's see I see
Bradley is there and the chat good to
see you hopefully some more mods will be
there I see a bunch of people from the
Facebook group Maryanne Laura Lee Neil
is there as there poor Robins are come I
did it if you go on social media you'll
see I posted two conversations ahead
with the band dirt for Robins and so
Neil is there in the in the chat he can
maybe post the link if he wants to I was
a lot of fun we talked about the
symbolism of their music their album
covers and we even talked about weird
things like Frankenstein The Wizard of
Oz - if I remember correctly so so
alright this month my goodness oh man I
wish I could I wish you know I wish I
wish I didn't have to say I told you
guys it's gonna get worse it just keeps
getting worse this year just keeps
getting worse and so we'll get through
it as you've noticed I've been putting
out more content in the past few weeks
you know content dealing with the
situation with the protests with the
strange religious let's say acts that
people have been doing I mean even the
patreon only video for this month has
been on that talking about foot washing
and so yes we're right in there as the
culture war rages hopefully we can look
at it with a clear mind and try to see
what's going on and how we can
understand it so hopefully those videos
have been helpful one of the things
that's been going on in the background
that that uh you know I I still really
want to point your attention to is that
on the website the symbolic worldcom we
now have a blog with a bunch of articles
written by different people and just a
few days ago someone Timothy asked
slaw I hope that's how we're not your
name Timothy asked for slaw he just put
up an article on minecraft called from
mines to mountains and it's very
interesting because he talked about
Minecraft itself but he also talks about
how video game creation needs to respect
the rules of a traditional world and so
they the way that they usually create
like this flat map with like a dome and
the further you get from the center of
the map the more things start to break
down and start to be more difficult to
calculate and so because of that
sometimes they get weird and anyways
it's very very interesting it is
definitely worth your your attention so
check that out on the symbolic worldcom
thanks for everybody who has been
supporting me I feel very touched
because I know it's been so weird and so
uncertain that um that I'm very touched
by those that want to continue to
support what I'm doing and as you know
those that that's for me at $10 or more
you get to ask questions in advance and
there are a lot of questions so
hopefully we can get through them and
then also if people want to ask
questions in the chat for now I'm just
going with the super chats because
because there's just too many questions
and so if I started to to look at the
chats themselves then we just it would
just be overwhelming so it's not the
perfect solution but for now it's the
best solution I've got alright and so I
will start answering the questions and I
usually start with my website so sort of
this symbolic world so Adam asks have
you ever given any thought of recording
a Bible study maybe something funded by
those interested sure that's definitely
possible you know there are too many
things to do and there's not enough time
and so I figure at some point that could
be that's you know I always thought that
the day that I run out of spontaneous
things to talk about then maybe I will
do something like like a more systematic
study of a text either text on the Bible
or maybe a fairy tale or myth and really
kind of read through it with you guys in
order to in order to really do a
deep-dive but uh that's not for right
now because right now there is enough
stuff to do so Josh the mover says hello
Jonathan why do early biblical figures
live for so long many hundreds of years
in some cases
I have heard a few different takes on
this and I'm curious to hear yours
so it's not it's not that early so the
idea would be to understand that it's
not early biblical figures it's it's
very specifically pre diluvian figures
and so before the flood there if you you
really have to understand the flood as a
change of world the flood is the end of
the world and so there are many things
which help us do let's say there are
many markers which help us understand
the difference between what's there
before the flood and what they're after
and the number of years my the best
understanding that I have of that is
that it has to do with the notion of
completion so you have this sense that a
thousand years would be the totality and
so you have these characters that die
short of a thousand years you know for
different reasons their sins make them
you know die short of a thousand years
or something like that um and so I think
that it has something to do with that it
and it also does really create the sense
of create the sense of a different world
that we don't totally cannot completely
connect with that it's a world of
greater men it's a world of a more
encompassing men men that men that had
more reach in terms of their being you
know that were closer to the to the top
of the garden right that even though
they fell they were still higher up on
the mountain the cosmic mountain so
that's the way that I understand that
and so what is the significance of the
number 40 in Scripture and tradition
well my sense that the number 40 is that
it's related to a cycle it's related to
a to a full cycle and so usually you
have these forty years forty days
all these these these numbers have to do
with this with this idea of a full cycle
that would go maybe through four
different quadrants you can understand
it like that for seasons or for whatever
and that it's a full full turn of that
of that wheel there's probably more
numerological reasons but I've often
told you might although I do have a
little bit of a sense of numerological
symbolism it's not my expertise some
people know a lot more than I do on that
so NC Watson asked how Jonathan do you
think a modern writer could recreate a
work like that of Dante when that unites
the personal historical mythological and
cosmological in other words could Dante
structure be given a new body and if so
what might that look like um I think so
I think that it would be possible but I
do think that I'm gonna meet
controversial with this one I really
think that Dante's work is not just the
work of an author I think that I think
that Dante I think that Dante's work is
connected to something more in the sense
that I really think Dante had a had a
vision of some kind or had a or he
himself had gone through what he was
describing maybe that's the best way of
understanding it is I think Dante wasn't
I think that Dante's work isn't a work
of fiction I think that Dante's work is
a work based on his experience and so do
with that what you will
do with that what you will alrightso new
Maya says I have been bothered by Paul's
statement in 1 Corinthians where he says
that those who are circumcised should
not become uncircumcised and those
uncircumcised should not be circumcised
he also states in Galatians that the one
who circumcised is obliged to obey the
the whole law someone who is Jewish and
believes in Christ I'm not sure how this
would apply to me or how to integrate my
identity with the body of Christ I
haven't
my whole life that has tried to deal
with this type of problem but I have
become more and more disillusioned I've
also tried to find examples in the past
but they are few and far between
especially the farther back it goes what
do you think would be a good starting
point in dealing with this so I would
say that a good way to maybe understand
it is to look at the very early church
and to look at the manner in which the
there was the the Church of the the Jews
and the Church of the Gentiles and so
you can see that in the iconography
really up to even up to the fifth
century you still have this idea of the
Church of the Jews and the Church of the
Gentiles there was this this notion
which really lasted for several
centuries and so maybe it would be
interesting to look at that and to look
at how early Christian Jews you know how
how they found their their place but in
the tradition of Christianity what ends
up happening is that the Jewish
community base this the the difference
between the Church of the Jews the
Church of the Gentiles just kind of
slowly goes away and it comes to a point
where you know as Christianity becomes
the religion of the of the Roman Empire
then it feels like the integration of
the faith and society has been more
complete and things like celebrating the
Sabbath will stop at some point and so
that's that's where you can kind of see
that the distinction goes away and and
that those would have been of Jewish
descent would not have would not have
been required to follow the all the Old
Testament rules there's also really is a
difference and it's very important to
understand it it's probably difficult
for people to realize that but there is
a difference because of the destruction
of Jerusalem that there's a difference
in Judaism that is Judaism is also born
with the destruction of the temple
Christianity and Judaism the way we
understand Judaism today I really come
about at the same time
you know there are no Jews today who are
doing sacrifices or doing the kinds of
things all of sacrificial law which is
really the center of the of Israel's
worship is gone when the temple gets
destroyed and so it's important to
understand that there is a
transformation which occurs there which
I think continues on and makes it so
that Christian Jews at some point are
not required to to follow all the all
the rules now as for the circumcised and
uncircumcised there is there is a
relationship in st. Paul there really is
a relationship between the way that he
talks so it really it's really useful if
you want to get a sense it's really
useful to read the Epistle to the
Hebrews and then read the Epistle to the
Romans like read those two in parallel
and it's going to be very fascinating to
see the type of language that is used to
talk up to talk there's a reason why in
the Epistle to the Romans there's this
emphasis on faith you know and on on
faith without the law and there's this
type of speaking which is addressed to
the Romans and probably he probably st.
Paul probably would not have said the
exact same thing to the Jews as well so
maybe that's a few two hints and I'm
sorry for your frustration I can
understand how that could be that could
be annoying
alright so Keenan Cronin says how is it
the death came into the world through
our fall but the dinosaurs were wiped
out long before we existed is it
possible that we disobeyed God in the
Garden outside of cosmic time which then
brought death in the world from the
beginning that's the only way that I can
make sense of this and I'd love to hear
how you reconcile the fact that death
and corruption seems to be around before
humans ever physically existed I think
Keenan you really just have to not mix
the narratives I know people will be
very unsatisfied at at the way that I
present this but the way that the story
is told in Scripture is just not the
same way that the scientists tell the
story and so when you try
to mix them together you create monsters
you create things that don't fit
together you have giants and hybrids and
weird weird monsters so I would say that
I would say that you need to look at it
in terms of narrative and not and try to
look at the Bible like some scientific
description of some phenomena that
happened I'm not saying that what
happened in Genesis didn't happen I
repeated this many times yes I do
believe it did happen but there are many
ways to describe something that happened
there isn't just one way and and so I
think the way that the scientists
describe what happened is just not the
same so I don't know what to say but in
terms of understanding this notion that
death came in with the fall I think that
I think that one of the interesting ways
that I've been thinking about recently
is the I the idea that death I've talked
about this relationship between death
and glory
so is that there is this sense in in for
example in the hymns to paradise that
the animals are outside of the garden
and there really is a tradition we've
talked about animality as being the same
as death and so the garments of skin the
garments of death which are added to to
adam are animal skins they're animal
garments and so even sang gregory of
nyssa says that which was you know dead
was added to our nature that which was
came from the animal world was added to
our nature and so there is also a hint
there that maybe you in an ontological
hierarchy you can understand that that
the animal aspect of creation had let's
say had a form of or represented or
manifested something that which would be
what we call death that there was a
there were there was more movement in
the in the outside of the garden but
that's really just speculation in a way
it's not totally necessary to to really
have to reconcile these but that could
be a way to for you to maybe think of it
differently that could help you to
to solve your your your suffering act ad
trying to reconcile these things
together
alright so Luka asked Kovac asks I know
this is a lot of questions backs into
one but basically okay here we go
what is your prediction opinion for the
far future what's what the future holds
for our civilization if this isn't the
true end the apocalypse if you will what
happens when people realize that
modernism and the modernist way of
thinking was a terrible idea
well we return to some form of medieval
epic will technology eventually break
down and fade away I think that when you
look at the story of the New Jerusalem
you get a sense that technology will not
the technology will be integrated
ultimately that in the ultimate reality
technology will be integrated in its
proper place that is it will the garden
in the middle and the tree of knowledge
of the Tree of Life the Tree of Life in
the middle and the water of life in the
middle and then on the outside you have
the walled city and so that technology
will have will be in its place and so
that's what I think is the ultimate
image that you find in Scripture now
what how that will happen and how that
will come about it might come about
we've you know it's seems if we read in
Scripture that the end of the world
comes about with a lot of a lot of pain
and destruction so I mean we've already
seen a lot of pain and destruction you
know some of the things that are
described in Revelation it's possible
that it's the type of thing that we
already saw in the 20th century like the
mass purges that millions of people
slaughtered the you know the the
ultimate total warfare the the so I mean
it's not it's not like we haven't really
had a glimpse of what you know
civilization falling into complete
conflict and complete chaos and the
great the last great battle could look
like and so I mean I don't know the
thing is I don't I what I see are
certainly patterns of
the end I'd see there are patterns of an
end now it's at the end of everything is
at the end of Western civilization is
the end of I don't know like I don't
want to I don't want to be too bold in
what I say but for sure the clown world
the
focus on the exception the desire to
account for everything you know the
technical technical see and also a we
can a let's say a reawakening of
spirituality but in a very dark way no
the fact that everybody is curious of
everybody's interested in spirituality
but they they they want a kind of
chaotic throughout everybody wants to
you know their angel or they meet these
these these beings that they that they
meet when they take drugs or whatever so
these this is this is this is dangerous
stuff it's like it really is like these
demonic hordes that are that are on the
edge of the world that are trying to
find cracks to come in you know and
that's what it feels like right now and
so so it doesn't look good but yeah all
right so Roxane asks isn't it important
to keep in mind that symbolism opens up
understanding to deeper meaning I'm
concerned about a tendency to want to
pin down meeting using symbol as one
uses straight pins for a butterfly
connection how can that danger be
avoided well the way that the danger is
avoid it is to you always is to
understand that symbolism only functions
through analogy function to analogy and
it also functions through structure so
you you always if someone's talking
about symbolism and isn't ultimately
talking about pattern and structure but
it's trying to to just say that this
thing means that then you can already
stop paying attention to what they're
saying because it's it's going to be
extremely trite it's I mean it's fine
like it's fine to understand I don't
know it's fine to understand that if
someone has an iron cross that it is a
it is an image of a prize that you win
for a certain type of reverie in the war
like I mean it's not completely void of
meaning but if you don't understand the
how it connects to a pattern a pattern
of ornament the
pattern of metal the pattern of adding
something to you to make you different
from others you know although if you
don't understand this other aspect of of
symbolism or how the cross becomes glory
like all of that then you're gonna miss
out and I mean it's fine like in normal
the in normal life you know it's good to
know that the iron cross is given by
this country to this type of person but
that's the way to avoid it the way to
avoid it is to always make is to always
look and see if the person is connecting
things to a broader pattern and is also
able to see analogies with other things
so if you're not able to see analogies
with other things then that's when the
interpretation is in danger if you've
noticed like if I every video I make I
maybe not every I hope every video I
make I'm always trying to give you let's
say the pattern of a version of that
pattern the one that appears in
Scripture and then usually I try to find
a really really surprising example like
something you hadn't thought of would be
connected to that so that you're it
you're able to say okay yeah okay this
it really is a pattern because you know
this stupid movie or this this strange
phenomena and culture is connected to
the same pattern so okay what is this
thing so Benjamin r-va asked what is
what is the significance of the
aesthetic of coolness and its ubiquity
as an ideal in our culture is it related
to prevalence of irony does it right
does it rise come at the cost of other
values I mean it's very simple coolness
is just that it's a symbol of power it's
a it's there it's a version of the
subversion of the idea of the snooty
elite right it's the idea of the elite
which is above things and is not
affected by things you know and so you
may you have this image of an aristocrat
who is extremely extremely has extreme
prowess in in doing something like he
can ride a horse you know in a really
amazing way but it doesn't bother him
busy so above it that you know it he
does
he acts very cool about it and so it
really is just an it really is just a
symbolism of that and so you know
obviously it depends on what level but
it's mostly about that it's about
looking looking detached from something
in order to announce that you have power
over it that you're better than
something
okay so Bogdan asks hi Jonathan what are
your thoughts on the meanings of dreams
I'm interested in Union dream reading
and I'm wondering if that technique as a
history in the church or if it can be
integrated into the Christian tradition
um I don't know a lot about Union dream
analysis I what I know about dreams is
that most dreams are meaningless
meaningless in the sense that they're
the idea of sleeping is that you go down
into death for a little bit you have a
little death you go down into chaos and
so your your mind and your body are
disconnected right so you have all these
thoughts right I mean your body is
moving around it's feels like it's not
connected to to your to your your your
mind right so you have this disconnect
it's a little death and so it's a one of
the things so most of the time it's just
like nonsense because it doesn't connect
with reality but once in a while it's it
becomes more like this idea of you can
imagine you can imagine something like
the idea of water that is very calm
right and so if if the your
consciousness is extremely calm and is
extremely centered then it is possible
that that death or that descendants of
the waters will become like a mirror and
then it will actually manifest it can
manifest something very very high and so
there are dreams of course you see it in
Scripture you see it in the tradition
there are Saints there are holy people
who can have prophetic dreams and those
dreams contain cosmic patterns in them
contain patterns which can help you even
understand you know what's going to
happen or the way in which reality
unfolds and so I think that that is
definitely possible
but I would say that it is rarer it is
rare but it
you can understand that it could also be
it could it could also be at a lower
level so you can imagine that a saint
would could have a cosmic dream because
the saint is so connected and so
centered that he actually becomes a
mirror for the entire cosmos but he
cannot you could imagine that if someone
could have a dream that is showing the
pattern of their psyche it's it's that I
don't think it's stupid to think that I
think that it makes sense but it would
remain to be seen whether or not whether
or not people are really capable of
interpreting those I don't know all
right so David flora says is Goldilocks
from the folktale Goldilocks and three
bears a representation of tyranny I've
been trying to figure this one out and
can only figure she represents the top
of a hierarchy because of her gold hair
and it was our actions of entering
someone's home and partaking in their
food with information know the story of
Goldilocks is is all about hospitality
it's all about it's all about the
problem of things that don't fit and the
relationship of hospitality to the
stranger so on the margin of the world
in the forests in the dark forests and
on the edges there are things that don't
fit there are things that don't connect
to you right they're too big they're too
small that you soft they're too hard
they're too hot too cold whatever it
doesn't matter
it's the idea is that they don't they
don't they're not they don't fit with
you and so that is what's going on
so Goldilocks goes into these houses and
nut and the things don't fit and then
she finds the things the thing that fits
with her but the in finding the thing
that fits with her on the outside she's
actually transgressing hospitality
because the relationship the
relationship between let's say the
outsider and the insider is that there
has to be a kind of buffer of distance
in order to respect each other's
identity and then so we encounter each
other as strangers right so that is the
that is the the proper relation of the
proper relation of
hospitality but let's say you you you
recognize something in your relationship
to the strange you see something that
has value for you and then you take it
right and that's us that's a story of a
lot of situations it's the story of
colonization the story of so many
situations where when you find something
in the stranger that you recognize you
end up transgressing hospitality you end
up taking and somehow so it can be it
could be the story could have very very
dark dark undertones if you understand
what's happening but that's really what
it's about until the the bear is in the
story or like the dog headed men right
they're like st. Christopher they're
like the the monsters on the edge of the
world they're these talking bears that
live in lived in there the this whole
idea of the the Barbarian right and so
thought that's what the Bears are and so
you need to find a normal relationship
with that which is outside of you all
right I probably need to speed up
because I think there's like 50
questions
all right Hugo okay so mathesar asks
hello my friend I really appreciated
your conversation with Andrea with the
bangs and surrounding myself up I wanted
to explore a bit more on the question of
masculine feminine I understand the
feminine as the matrix in which reality
comes into being is that right yes
that's a good way to see it or at least
one aspect of it the masculine has the
principle in which meaning comes
together is that right I would say that
the meaning comes together we could
understand it as the seed or the
principle and so the the coming together
happens as they join together right as
the mask and your family come together
laughs where they're coming together
happens that's where that's where the
that the consummation happens that's
where the union of opposites that's
where the child is formed right that's
the coming together is the trial you
have the seed you have the womb you have
the child right and that's that that's
it um okay so my main question is
related to the nature of the primacy of
masking over feminine Adam came before
Eve and Christ pre-exists married and
yet Eve
Adam to fall and Mary gives birth to
Christ and this there seems a mystery
could you elaborate on this a bit more
oh my goodness there is definitely a
mystery there is definitely a mystery
there and st. Paul knows there's a
mystery st. Paul knows there's a mystery
I forget that the the reference of the
passage but st. Paul talks about this
when he says you know every every man
comes from a woman the first woman came
from man every man comes from a woman
and then he taught it and he says I say
this about Christ and His Church there's
this like there's this very interesting
relationship ain't saying that from the
Syrian in in his comment on that text of
st. Paul he goes he goes intense because
he then connects which st. Paul doesn't
do say Paul just says there's the
mystery there but Saint Ephrem the
Syrian goes went further and then he
connects the the masculine coming from
the feminine to the divine nature of God
as the divine womb and the and God
manifesting himself out of the divine
womb and so it's like wow so the it's
going to be very difficult for you to
find the the causality right because it
just depends on which side you're
looking from the infinite itself is
neither masculine or feminine the origin
of all things and so it's it's as if
what you're seeing and the stories is
the the the way of describing it is
flipped in different stories right like
you said so so Eve comes from Adam but
then all of man come from Eve and then
the the church is the Christ is born out
of Mary but then the church is born out
of Christ's side etc etc etc there's
this like there's this relationship of
causality which if you take both at the
same time can maybe point you to a
mystery which is above it which cannot
be uttered maybe that's the best way for
me to describe it
so Diaz bru says would you ever consider
an interview with father Moses berry and
or to real quarrels from the Fellowship
of say Moses the black conversation
about how to
integrate the outsiders into the heart
could not see more timely considering
the current state of affairs I think
that's a good idea
you know I have I met father Moses a few
times and I had a very good contact with
him and same thing with father turbo
I've had several exchanges with him
through messenger through email we've
talked about my article on San
Christopher and different things like
that so yeah I would be very happy I I
it's it's I'm not really good at
organizing interviews but uh but yeah
that might be good yeah it might be
interesting to talk to father turbo um
yeah they both have very interesting
stories as well so that could be
interesting
I'll think about it so Luca asks Kovac
asks no that's not a question
okay so Jacob asks Oh Jacob Jacob
Russell asking questions
are you there Jake oh by the way I see
Lisa's there hey Lisa
good see you once in a while try to like
just seems like maybe Jacobs not around
all right well I will answer your
question nonetheless Jacob even if
you're not there I feel I feel left out
all right okay so Jacob says I have had
many wonderful conversations about what
its symbol is in the Internet's I found
with the I found with the uncommon use
of the depth of the definition nerds
like us use for symbol others try to use
a different word to make sense of these
ideas the most common has been metaphor
which seems at its root to mean a
transfer of meaning with no gathering
gathering yes instead of talking once
more on what a symbol is could you riff
on how metaphor might or might not be
used to talk about meaning purpose and
symbol I mean look I don't really I
don't really care what word we use I use
the word symbol because in the word
symbol there is the meaning that I'm
trying to refer to and like you like you
said I think that metaphor can be a
problem because it does indeed tend to
emphasize the distinction between the
levels and I and I in myself when I talk
about things I tend to
to really create that distinction
because what happens is you have people
and you've seen it all the time is that
they they don't see the structural
meaning they see the relationship
between the coming together the elements
of the meaning as an arbitrary
relationship as a kind of weird jump
that has nothing to do with the actual
structure of reality and so and so I
think that like I definitely prefer the
word the word symbol and that's probably
just you use that but if someone uses
the word metaphor don't get hung up
about it you know it that's usually not
helpful in the discussion the best thing
to do so just try to see what they're
talking about and try to understand
whether or not they believe that there
are structural reasons like that that
something is an instantiation of itself
right that that's what symbolism is
right and so the branch of a tree is the
instantiation of the same pattern as the
tree itself so that's symbolism it's a
it's a it's when the pattern the the
thing that symbolizes the pattern is an
instantiation of the pattern it's not
just a it's not just a random literary
connection right it's not a disconnected
set of things all right so bleeding
mermaid asks I loved watching your
discussion this month with Owen Cyclops
can you give us your thoughts on
astrology and the zodiac obviously
astrology is condemned to Christianity
and can easily be idolatrous but I think
the zodiac can also have a great insight
on principalities as well as some
interesting symbolic understanding a
space of time would appreciate any
thoughts you have on the subject
thanks well despite the fact that that
astrology was condemned by Christianity
I think that the aspect which is
condemned by Christianity is more
soothsaying
than it is astrology in the sense that
it's more the idea of wanting to use
phenomena in order to predict the future
that for sure is
is not accepted in Christianity but the
idea that astrology has not been a part
of Christianity that's just not true you
know in the Middle Ages every King and
Byzantine Empire every Emperor would
have had their zodiac chart done they
would have had their astrological place
you could say like that traits they
would have known their place in the
cosmic dance you could say and so I
don't have a problem with the idea that
the pattern of the movement of the stars
would be related to the cosmic pattern I
don't see why that would be a problem I
think that you know I think that the
movement of the the the heavenly bodies
definitely especially if we're the ones
looking at them and especially because
there are there are so many there's an
innumerable amount of them and so when
we look at this infinite amount of dots
in the sky and then we trace patterns so
it is a form of relevance realization to
use to use a genre vacant idea is that
what will come out of that cosmic
infinite is going to be pattern and
those patterns will be the patterns of
reality there's no way around it there
will be arbitrary they will end up they
will end up representing manifesting the
patterns of of our stories that cosmic
patterns of that's why there's a
relationship in mozo Biak systems
between the mythological stories and
patterns that they that they pulled out
of the of the heavens right and so I
don't I don't particularly have a
problem with astrological symbolism I
think my problem with astrological
symbolism is that I think that it's
misunderstood today I think that I think
that nobody understands that symbolism
anymore and most of the people who who
they say they understand it they're
they're they're bunk like they're making
it up they
they don't get it it's a lost
it's a lost symbolism in my opinion I
don't I've never I have rarely seen
anything I mean it's not like I've
researched it immensely but all this
stuff i-team related to the zodiac has
always been kind of bumped and like I
said because it's used today mostly as a
form of soothsaying
as a form of trying to affect reality or
or interpret react or interpret the
future or try to predict the future then
in that sense I think that it's it's
probably not very good and I would say
that most people who spend their time I
mean if you read your horoscope I really
think it's useless I don't think it's
gonna help you at all but you know I
don't if you look at ancient cathedrals
they would they would show the signs of
the zodiac in their iconography because
it was this idea of this cosmic spheres
disease this cosmic movement which was
the pattern reality that Christ had
created but if you think about it's not
silly it's not silly to think when you
look at the sky there are so many stars
that who decides what the patterns are
in those stars like where do those
patterns come from they don't come from
the stars they come from the connection
of our consciousness to the Stars and
the connection of that to the pattern
that we live in and that we understand
so it's not I don't find it I don't find
it problematic at in principle but like
I said I don't think it's understood
today I think mostly it's just it's just
bunk all right ok so here we go so I'm
going to subscribe star now let me just
make sure that I've got all the
questions or comments on my website here
I think so
ok that's Christopher I'm sorry all
right so so Aaron lectin burger asks so
forgive me if this question is
unanswerable because I am NOT observing
the wider culture pretty well but why
are political narratives taking up so
much headspace inside people why aren't
people's narratives about small things
like having food
good friendships or doing a good job at
work or school I see an implicit
devaluation of all small things and I'm
not sure where it's from well one of the
places it's from is people need to feel
like they're connected to something
bigger than them you know and so that's
inevitable we have to feel like we're
connected to a bigger pattern and so
that's why politics is always so
important because it is the manner in
which we are connected to the people
around us it is the markers politics
contains the markers contains the
narratives which bind us together as
people in our nation know in our cities
or whatever and so it's very it is
important it's very important um now one
of the problems we have of course is
because of social media and because we
are bombarded with the the political
narrative is that it that is one of the
reasons why I can become obsessive and
people can be completely filled filled
with that that space you know and
especially because because of the social
crisis because there is a social crisis
there is there the social crisis is
getting more intense the you know the
fight the cultural war is there and it's
real so because of that it's it's also
inevitable that people would be more
taken by it because you know it feels
like the fabric of their society is
being threatened you know but I do agree
that I still think that the main
solution to the problem is is to focus
on your own sins to focus on your own
passions to love your neighbor you know
um at least for now
you know all right
so here we go XRD thoughts on pacifism
the Christian denomination that my
mother belongs to is a hundred percent
on the side of pacifism I think their
argument being that if violence comes to
you it means it's meant to happen but
that seems like it's discounting free
will
um I yeah I'm not a pacifist I don't I
don't
with pacifism I think that I don't think
that Christian that nations need to to
be to not engage in conflict if that's
necessary I I don't necessarily I don't
see the things that Christian said as
opposing the capacity of a nation to
defend themselves you know if they're in
danger or the capacity from you to
defend your family if you're in danger I
think there's another question here
about the turning the other cheek and so
maybe when I get to that other question
I can continue on the subject but um but
no I I don't I think that when people
are pacifists they misunderstand the
thing that Christ is talking about our
Dorothy KK asked what is the issue with
some Protestants and Constantine to me
it seems a little illogical to fight the
culture war into one a Christian society
and at the same time declare that
Christianity died of Constantine you
open the door to exactly that right some
argument that it seems that part of it
is misinformation and misinterpretation
what are your thoughts well yeah I don't
understand it I mean I guess I was there
for a while so I could see it it's very
strange
it's very very strange because the thing
is that Christianity as we know it and
even the Christianity the Protestants
believe in the Trinity that the dual
nature of Christ
you know the the Canon the there's so
many things that Christians believed
that you know that came about during the
time of Constantine and so you know
Protestants need Augustine progress they
need Saint Athanasius they need they
need these thinkers for their system to
to make sense and so it's just odd it's
just odd that at the moment when
Christianity was was was the day
manifesting itself fully then
and that's the moment where that's their
problem and it mostly has to do with
Rome and an objection to Rome that's
mostly what it is and so it's mostly it
it's trying to find the because the
Protestants oppose Rome then they wanted
to find the place where they could
pinpoint the original sin of
Christianity and they go all the way
back to Constantine but it is not a
thought-out position and I think that
most intelligent Protestants most
cultured Protestants who have studied
history really can't hold that position
even if they don't like Constantine I
think that they need to understand that
you know the Christian what constantine
brought lifted the time of constantine
is the time of the church at the time of
of the things you believe in it's a time
where those things you know manifested
themselves so alright so nicola asks
when you consider doing architectural
reviews of some orthodox churches or
monasteries that are of particular note
any comments on the new main cathedral
of the russian armed forces in moscow ah
they've made some bold design decisions
ie the glass roof and the golden statues
of Christ above the altar area yeah it's
something it is something I need let me
pull it up right now
it is very much it is very much a a
church of of glory right it is a church
a lot of people say it's a Church of
imperialism but it's definitely a church
which is celebratory and so is it a
statue above the altar or is it a relief
I think it's a relief it's not a sketch
um look I don't I don't have a problem
with with this I know a lot of people do
I don't have a problem with this I think
you know I think that how can you how
can you look at at how
yeah Sofia and think it's beautiful how
can you look at you know the the norman
cathedrals in Sicily and think they're
amazing and beautiful and then at the
same time feel embarrassed by by
something like this so I know
particularly I'm not particularly
bothered with the fact of this Cathedral
know the glass the glass roof is little
is a little weird in my opinion but
that's that's really more my vision of
the church as a also as a kind of cave
you know as it's kind of closed nativity
area but yeah I know I don't
particularly a problem with with that
church alright let's go back to the
questions here okay alright so actually
I think we're done with subscribe star
and we're going into patreon patreon is
the most always has the most so there's
like there's like 26 questions here so
who you might have to rush through some
of these all right here you go okay so
Paul du mal I think as I brown sit ask
hi Jonathan you mentioned that most of
our modern storytelling comes from
talking could you briefly explain expand
on that idea failed to understand what
you mean well what I'm talking about is
not just storytelling but it's a certain
kind of storytelling it's that it's the
it's the world-building storytelling you
know it's the nerd nerd storytelling
type of storytelling that undergirds
things like Marvel Comics or that
undergird things like Harry Potter the
kind of story in which a world is
constructed and then the actors of that
world interact with each other that is
what I knotted what I'm talking about
and so I think that that really does
come from from toking also toking
crystallized the whole idea of fantasy
and magic and all of this that we see
everywhere right he he basically I mean
it was probably already happening but he
crystallized the notion that the
Middle Ages are the mythic is the mythic
time of our culture it's it's this it's
this past that goes into the mists and
that has all this kind of dreamy aspect
to it this magical aspect to it you know
and so he was able to really crystallize
that and I don't think people have
really gotten rid of it yet you know
it's still there it's still there you
know underlying our culture so so that's
what I mean hopefully that helps you
understand so Christian soccer asks do
you think the opening of Christ sign of
the Cross is meant to connect to the
opening of Adam side the opening of Adam
brought out Eve and the opening of
Christ brought out the Bride of Christ
ie the trick yes that is that is
explicitly mentioned in the liturgical
texts and so during the during the the
celebration of the crucifixion of Christ
during Holy Week you you hear that being
said or being chanted in in the liturgy
so it is definitely connected to that
Ryan Pinkham asks what do you think of
king st. Louis the night
I mean I'm French what can I say you
know I like king st. Louis I mean he's a
complex figure he's a he's a complex
figure but he's an interesting figure
he's very interesting he did a lot of
amazing stuff his story his personal
story is very touching because he seems
to have been a very devout person and
loved his wife and and you know he he
introduced the presumption of innocence
in the system the legal system he heeds
that he ended the alba gentian crusade
he you know he did a bunch of stuff that
were pretty impressive he he was part of
the connection between the French and
the Mongols he entertained the
relationship between the Mongolian
Empire and the Christian West you know
and there are these all these crazy
stories of that time with
where you know there were these letters
sent and the mongolian the mongols would
send letters saying that they knew where
prester john was and pressor john who
don't know was like this mythical
christian king that lived in the east
and so yeah it's really an interesting
time for anybody was interested it's a
very very interesting time and so yeah i
mean you know he's he there's his
crusading wasn't particularly successful
if you at least that's my understanding
but uh but i would say that all in all
he's a he's a pretty admirable character
alright here we go
so Neal the grade which I mentioned and
check out his new album during for
Robbins check out check it out Neal
posted in the chat I know you're there
so posted for people to go to your your
to your website into our discussions so
Neal asked hey Jonathan so many
conspiracy theories floating around
right now oh my goodness is there one
that jumps out as the most interesting
to you as far as its symbolic structure
alright okay so man you guys are gonna
get me in trouble with YouTube for
talking about this stuff but um I think
that the most interesting conspiracy
that's around right now in terms of the
symbolism is definitely the whole the
whole vaccine and microdot thing the
connection between the vaccine and
identification but not just
identification but identification which
would be like attached to your body that
you could scan I think that that is
really very fascinating in terms of you
know and it opens up certain ideas in
terms of understanding what the
symbolism of 666 is and I talked about
that in some of my in my videos on 666
the idea of accounting for the
accounting for the exception or wanting
to account for everything and the idea
of accounting for disease
because a vaccine is basically being
injected with an aspect of the disease
so that you develop you know antibodies
against it so the idea that you could be
identified related to a disease that we
could account for those who have had or
not had a disease and that this type of
accounting would be the marker which
would either which would permit you to
function in society or not so there's
this weird connection between accepting
accepting a mark accepting to be marked
to be identified and the disease and how
this could be used as an other door at
the barrier or
an opening to whether or not you're able
to fully reintegrate society so I think
that that's very interesting it's
interesting to think about and so I mean
I've been thinking about maybe doing a
maybe doing a video on the double
symbolism of vaccination I'm trying to
get my brother met you to do it with me
but uh that's really tough but yeah I've
been thinking about trying maybe doing
that because mostly we've talked about
vaccination as being very positive in in
our former in my former videos and my
writings you know I talked about this
idea of the of death fighting death but
I but there is a dark side as well so I
think I mentioned this in another Q&A to
of the dark side of that so maybe I'll
make a video at some point maybe I'll
put it on [ __ ] shoot or something so
that I don't get so I don't get banned
from YouTube all right okay would stay
posted on that so mark Kalashnikov I'm
sure that if that's your real name mark
seriously dude that's amazing
so mark Kalashnikov asks hi Jonathan I
was wondering if you had any comments on
reflections the blessing of Jacob in
Genesis 49 especially from verse 10
starting with Judah and so on I've never
heard anyone speak on the subject there
seems to be some interesting symbolic
nugget that I that are worded in rather
cryptic language yeah there's definitely
interesting stuff there I don't think I
could do that right here at the top of
my head I would really need to reread
the text in advance and talk about it so
sorry
maybe that's something I can do at some
point in the video so Ronelle Canada ask
good evening Johnson this is my first
question so I'm pretty excited thanks
for all you do well you're welcome
anyway how can one correctly in
accordance to God's will pursue the
Alexander the Great archetype not
necessarily in the ruler sense but more
in the skill mastery sense if you have a
more app representative for the sort of
idea I'm trying to espouse in my
question could you use that I asked it
because of the ax man I used my free
time to pick up various skills like
programming drawing musical instruments
et cetera and I obviously want to be
successful but I want these skills and
the positions they may arise from
knowing them in order to be a vessel for
the Lord I guess another way to ask the
question then would be how do we how can
we strive for greatness without ego to
aim and being fruitful and useful but in
a way that's honorable to God I mean I
think that I think that you you've got
it I mean I think you've got it in your
in your question you already have the
answer which is that if you just develop
a skill like programming it's like a
tool it's like you know it it doesn't
give you the purpose and so by directing
the purpose of what you're doing like
drawing or programming or music music
then that is how you can make them into
vessels for God right and so the idea of
the neutral scientist is or the neutral
skilled person is just not true right so
that is how you can that is how you can
do it all what you need to do is to
always ask yourself what is my skill
directed towards is that something which
honors God or is it something which
honors just my own ego or the passions
or the passions of others I think that's
the question
alright so hello Jonathan I've always
had a conflicted view
when Christ says we should turn the
other cheek yeah this is the one I saw
before if someone comes after you
personally I can take it but if someone
comes after my family or the people I
love I don't see how I can stand and not
fight back feel like I'm missing
something and that frayed but I don't
know what PS I've started participating
in an Orthodox Church near me thank you
for all your words so this really comes
back to the whole problem of pacifism
now one of the things that I've tried to
to tell you guys and really tried to
emphasize is that there are very few
things that Christ says I would say
right Christ's message is not ethics
Christ's message is not a form of
morality it's just not and and when we
try to interpret what Christ is saying
as strictly a moral code of some kind
then we want to ride because that's just
not what he's talking about
and so I'm not saying that there isn't a
moral I'm noting that there isn't a
moral aspect which will flow from what
Christ is saying but that is definitely
not the purpose and so when Christ says
we need to turn the other cheek
it's not about pacifism it is about it
is about not being a slave to the
outside it's about not that your action
not your actions not be dictated by what
is outside you so it's related to not
giving in to passion right that's the
idea of what a passion is the word
passion means that you are shut you were
you were subjugated to that which is
outside you're not in control of
yourself
and so when Christ says to turn the
other cheek that's what that's when
that's what he's talking about he's
talking about that if someone hits you
and you react and you hit them back then
you are making that person you are
giving that person power over your will
you are making them in charge of what
you're going to do whereas if you're
able to turn the other cheek and you do
it by not being a coward and that's
really important because
you know I always kind of to say it's
like if I turn the other cheek because
I'm scared then that's not what Christ
is talking about right that has nothing
to do with what Christ is talking about
or it's not saying be a coward and turn
the other cheek he's saying don't let
others dictate your will don't let
others decide what your action is going
to be and so and so and so I think that
it does not prevent Christians from even
Christians from defending themselves in
certain certain situations you know
defending their family for sure
defending their nation for sure
defending their their land defending all
these things is completely acceptable
there's nothing there's nothing wrong
with that as a Christian to to defend
your the people around you right and
it's not referring to that at all I
don't I really don't see how and and the
reason for the reasons why it's it's not
that is that it was never interpreted
that way the the Christians had armies
Christians had nations Christians had
had soldiers and no and when st. Paul
talks through the Roman soldiers he
tells them he doesn't tell them stop
being a soldier you got to you Paskus no
he says be just in the way you act right
don't abuse your power right um and so
that's what I would say about that
hopefully that helps all right so Jael
asks am i right in thinking that the
only people coining new words are
scientists and internet youth is the
blind acceptance of the alphanumeric
string Cova 19 from the charming
coronavirus an indication of the utter
value we put on science is the adoption
of specialist jargon by the masses a bad
sign or am I reading too much into it
love your work ah you know it's weird
because I haven't thought about that I
really have thought about why everybody
was first people were saying coronavirus
and then they started saying Cove in
nineteen a lot and then Coburn and he
kind of took over and I really did think
it was it had something to do with what
you're saying it had something to do
with there is too much symbolism in the
coronavirus there's just too much
symbolism
word and so it was I think that
intuitively was kind of kind of
bothersome and because we don't want it
to be full of meaning you know we wanted
to be this like neutral thing that's
happening and I think that that giving
it a name like that like a
science-fiction name was probably a way
I don'ts not saying people did it on
purpose but it was a way to kind of
deescalate the meaning which was which
was bound into what was going on
all right so kind of Mitchell asked
again about the the new military
Cathedral so yeah I think I answered
that I think answered that I think it's
a bit over the top but I I'm fine with
that because it is what it is right it's
it's not a humble chapel in a village
it's a it's a chapel to remember the the
sacrifices of the of the soldiers who
died for their country and who were
Christian and so yeah I don't doesn't
bother me
alright so AJ doll Torrio asks hey
Jonathan I hope you're doing well my
question is regarding music in the
Orthodox Church is there a reason that
no instruments are allowed I often watch
praise and worship concerts and so it's
cool to see people connecting we got in
that way thank you um I mean it really
does have to do with a notion that this
is the way I understand it okay I mean
people have different different ways of
interpreting it but one of the ways it
helps me understand it is to understand
that we need to see that the the church
is really it really is moving into
communion of people right it is the
coming together of the body of Christ
and so you have to kind of understand
the coming the the one voice of the
church right that because there's a
discussion even there's really it's a
really interesting because you'll see
that people intuitively kind of
understand it because there's discussion
about about polyphony in Orthodox
churches for example some people think
that there should be polyphony there
shouldn't be several voices there just
be one voice right but you can
understand then what is happening the
notion is that it's it's us uniting our
right our logos together with the logos
of others together in one voice and
raising that up and participating and
entering into the the presence of God
and so that's the way that I that I
understand it mark Peters as you
Jonathan please clarify our comment you
made on the lack of efficacy when
elevating the host in the consecration I
can't find the exact quote when you were
talking about Galileo in the same sense
no I was not at all ah I was not at all
making a point on the lack of efficacy
when elevating those in the consecration
I was not at all doing that I was doing
the very opposite what I was doing is I
was saying that if you tried to adhere
to a strictly materialist point of view
if you tried to make science your first
frame of meaning then raising the host
up is mean it's stupid it's a stupid
thing because where are you what are you
doing when you lift up the the host if
you're purely a materialist right it's
because you have Christians like that
you have Christians that are that are
that that really want to frame the world
in terms of materialism right and so
it's like if you if you're a materialist
and you want the Bible to be all about
science and be all about this then
raising the host up is like when you're
putting it up so that it can catch the
Wi-Fi signals I said something like that
wait you're not doing that of course
because because the the the the reality
of hierarchy manifests itself really
ontological II by things being higher up
it's it's a real it's a real
transformation like go up a mountain
it's a real transformation it's not it's
not it's not it's not just a metaphor
it's not it's not you know it's real so
that's what I was referring to
hopefully that I said it was the very
opposite of trying to suggest that there
was a lack of efficacy so Emmy asked
what is the symbolism of factories if
man is made to spend time tending the
garden and turning raw materials into
more glorious things what happens when
he turns part of the creation into
something that does this for him yes I
mean factories are definitely part of
the the alienation that come
in the modern world you know this this
reduction to the task and the idea of
making people into machines that's what
factories are factories are and you can
see the reason you can see that's what
it is because if they could get rid of
all the people they would right and
because they can't then they turn people
into machines so it's it really is a
machine world to create quantity and the
value of the art isn't the value of
human making is lost and the human
worker and the factory worker becomes
alienated yeah so Airy Fischer asks
hello Jonathan in your last video you
were asked about the importance of a
good translates when reading the Bible
and you replied by giving an example of
learning Genesis that was supposedly
more correct the symbolic structures if
it said and God created the sea serpents
yeah something that I went looking for
looking and couldn't find a translation
that said that the closest said reptiles
hahaha basically I'm just wondering if
you could recommend a specific
translation of the Bible or the one that
you use thanks for everything you do you
have taught me much I mean to be honest
like I just used the King James Version
and then I if I have a more specific
question then I will go online and look
at an engineer Bible and I will look at
you know you can find can find Strong's
Concordance where you have forget what's
the name of the website is but there's a
website where you can you can look at an
interim into your Bible and you have the
English and the Hebrew and then you have
you can click on the words and the words
will give you the definitions of those
words and stuff so that's really helpful
um I also asked my brother that's my
brother because he is quite fluent in
Hebrew that helps but that's if that's
what the word is tannin it means big sea
serpent sir means serpent really but
it's implied it's a sea serpent so Jay
mute asks is that Jeffrey he's a
geoffrey Mutai yeah Jay I'm happy to see
you back by the way Jeffrey I'm really
happy to see you you pop up again so I'm
looking forward to talking to you soon
alright so Jeffrey Muir says when the
world is up
where's the King sir examples might be
helpful when the world is upside down
the king is hiding so good examples Lord
of the Rings hidden King King David and
scripture that's really good that's a
really good example when the King when
the King is is hiding amongst the people
and it's like you can imagine it really
like in the upside-down world it's
people struggle to see the King right
they can't see the King because they
can't see hierarchy they can't even you
can't see they can't see what is more
valuable and so because of that the king
is hiding like the pearl in the field
all right Christopher Coretta asks hi
Jonathan
a lot of hay is being made about the
parallel between woke and religion and
fair enough there are many however I
think the opposite distinction needs to
be made the new atheist types are
already putting religion and woke is
this the same box of things dumb people
believe because they're irrational
in what ways is woke not a proper
religion well it's not a proper religion
because it's not it's not aimed at the
highest thing it's not aimed at things
that are high enough and so because of
that it becomes what your leaders are
talks about in the sense of a caricature
of religion and it becomes a kind of
fake religion you know a pseudo religion
and you see the pseudo religions are all
over the place they're everywhere
they're in there in manga culture and
they're in video game culture people
become obsessed with certain things now
and in the sense of the woke aspect it's
scary because it's now it's a political
movement so it's it's similar to
communism really especially the the
current wave is very communist you know
and so because of that it is really a
parody of of Christianity a parody of
religion so now the thing that the thing
that the new atheists are saying they're
missing the point again
just missing the point because they
don't understand that it's gonna come
back again and it's gonna come back
again and again and again because it's
part of us so you can pretend or you can
pretend and say oh look at those stupid
people that are doing that right but
it's it's as if you thought sleeping was
stupid and then you when people fall
asleep you go oh look at those stupid
people falling asleep it's like dude
people fall asleep you just can't avoid
it and so that's it
so the new atheists are are deluding
themselves and they are riding on the
coattails of us of a civilization which
is falling apart and they think that
this is the normal course of things it's
not
if there are no unifying principles
society falls apart it's very simple
there's nothing uniting things together
they fall apart it's not it's not not
rocket science so so they don't have
anything to offer us they have nothing
they have nothing to offer us which
would hold us together and so they can
decry all they want when they see the
religious impulse go go nuclear and go
crazy like we're seeing right now but
they have nothing to offer so yeah all
right I'd be curious to see if they
really are Steven Pinker saying anything
about this these protests is he is he's
I'm not I don't think he is I've
enlisted to Sam Harris I'd be curious to
see what he says
maybe Sam Harris would but Steven Pinker
he's got major blind spots all right
okay so Harmon Smith says of course
Santa Claus exists but did he always
exist for memory and record of Santa
Claus and the associated traditions
vanish from the earth would Santa Claus
continue to exist let's ask that in
another way now use that again for
anything everything that exists ask that
same question again does a chair exist
we did if if if all memory and record of
chairs and the associated traditions
from the earth wood chairs continue to
exist so that's the I would I guess I
would ask that back at you and wonder ok
I'm gonna answer the question I know any
of you a jerk human beings have a
particular function in creation human
beings have a particular function of
mediating between heaven and earth and
so a lot of things exist through humans
and and so when you say something when
you say would they would they but they
cease existing if all humanity vanished
then the answer is right the answer is
yes they would because humans humans
participate in their existence because
we are the mediators of heaven and earth
so much is like I guess that's the best
I could I could say and so Santa Claus
needs of needs a body for him to exist
and so if there was no connection
between the principle and the and the
manifestation then Santa Claus would
also would cease to exist properly busy
would have no body all right okay so
Jason Lindsey hey Jonathan is it
possible for a fallen angel or principal
to be saved or redeemed that's tough man
I have heard st. Augustine touches on
the subject and I've been reading
through his confessions on and off if it
is possible are there any examples of
either canonical or apocryphal stories
where a fallen angel is redeemed and
forgiven if not why is it that a fallen
angel is forever lost thank you for any
help and insight into these questions
man that is some tough that's a tough
question I would say the official answer
is no the official answer is no because
so the way that it said in terms of
stories like the way that it's represent
in terms of stories is the idea that the
angels fell before creation something
like that or they fell before the
creation of the world they fell once and
for all so when it when it refers to is
that it's a they
there they place themselves direct the
principality's have places in an
ontological hierarchy some facing up and
some facing down you would say and so
the aspect that's facing down is facing
down it's just facing down so that's
that's the official answer you know and
there's a lot of people that have tried
to deal with it CS Lewis has tried to
deal with this question and I would say
there's no ultimate answer you know
because then you start talking about a
polka tossed assist which it's tricky
stuff to talk about and it's things that
I don't really like to talk about the
idea of a universal restoration because
it's it's not useful so sorry I'm kind
of not answering your question all right
so norm grande asks I'm reading the
language of creation and have a question
about time space so space is described
as the power that builds a consistent
and stable reality while time is
described as the mystery that subverts
and overturns existing reality with
inconsistency and contusion my question
is about the seemingly negative aspect
of time from the standpoint of creation
are we meant to understand this in terms
of God leaving a fringe on creation a
place to deal with ambiguity or
transformation renewal as it's
counterpoint to rigor and possible
tyranny I place the whole mystery of
what has yet to be if it is ever to be
revealed to man yes it's the Sabbath
that's the Sabbath does the Sabbath is
all about that mystery right and the
Sabbath is the proper integration of
that mystery that's the best way I can
answer that
okay so Matthew Marinelli
asks st. Ambrose in his homilies on the
six days of creation writes the earth is
not to spend it in the middle of the
universe like a balance hung in
equilibrium but the majesty of God holds
it together by the law of his own it
continues when we read I have
established the pillars thereof we
cannot believe that the world has
supported was supported by actual
but rather by that power that props up
the substance of the earth and sustains
it can you extrapolate on this I think
many people modern people would be
completely confused by what st. Ambrose
is saying but these sentences seem to be
the key to understanding symbolic
thinking so natural for the church
fathers I mean I think it's a good way
for it's a good way for st. Ambrose to
deal with the issue let's say of the
change in cosmology which was happening
at the time in terms of moving already
towards more mechanistic understanding
so what he's saying is when we use the
and and I think that it's a it's a good
way to to make to make the transition
like I do it all the time I do what st.
Ambrose is doing I do it all the time
it's like when when we talk about
pillars it is a structural description
of how reality holds together and so if
you dig underground physically you won't
find pillars underneath holding things
up right but if you want to understand
how Earth and the substance of things is
holding is held together then pillars
you know especially a right and a left
pillar is a good way to understand it's
a good way to to explain how things are
held together they need they need them
they need two pillars they need a right
hand and a left hand pillar they need a
pillar which which manifests the inner
movement and a pillar that manifests the
outer movement something like that but
they needed a they need a structure
which which makes identity possible okay
so I think that you're right I think
that that's and Ambrose is basically
saying something similar to the things
that I'm saying right he's basically
pointing to how the the analogies that
we use especially when we talk about the
very nature of reality obviously have to
they're using images of the world and
they're the those images are real
instantiations of the pattern
but we're using that image and analogy
to talk about something which is
invisible and something which is beyond
manifestation so and then so when we
talk about the earth and the sense of
the primordial earth described in
Scripture you know the one that is that
is chaos and void obviously we're not
talking about manifestation in the way
we understand it we're talking about the
very substance of reality so yes I agree
thanks for that but it's a great quote
I'm gonna keep that try to find it if
you find the the citation like if you
have the I'd love to get I love to have
that
so Nico asks hi Jonathan I think for all
your work probably I wouldn't be a
Christian without it I'm Gloria glory to
God for that my question is what have we
learned about symbolism after the Middle
Ages is there anything that has been
added or dismissed or has there been a
change of focus um I've been thinking
about this a lot actually I've been
thinking about this and wondering what
the advantage of today is over let's say
the liminal ages I think that a way to
understand it it's maybe a difference it
can be a disadvantage and an advantage
is because we've actually moved away
from it's as if they live in the Middle
Ages people were wearing glasses and
we're looking at the world through
glasses and so the everything was just
as intuitive structure was just like
they didn't have to explain it and so
then as we moved away from the Middle
Ages people took off the glasses and put
on another pair of glasses look back and
started saying how stupid the world was
before because they weren't wearing the
same glasses so everything looks strange
and odd and so I think that one of the
advantages we have now is that because
now we've trying to take off the modern
glasses and we're trying to put on back
on the symbolic glasses but we haven't
lost we haven't lost the memory of the
other world view so so it means that
this means that we end up explaining I
mean that's I've said this before too is
the reason why I explain symbolism is
because because we have gone very far
away from it and so now we're away or
far
so now we have to explain it so that
people will want to move back towards it
so that is an advantage but it's also a
disadvantage because there there remains
a form of alienation when I'm explaining
symbolism rather than doing it and
that's why if you aren't if you look at
my life you look at my you look at what
I'm doing it's mostly trying to bridge
those two things together you know
there's a reason why I spend half of my
time carving icons you know there's a
reason why I do that it's because I when
I'm carving icons I'm trying to be in
the world and I'm trying to not explain
it but actually be making things that
are participating in that pattern world
and it's different from when I'm
stepping out and then analyzing things
so so that's been my way to deal with it
at least
alright so JD asks is post-modernism a
flood it's very similar to a flood for
sure yeah very much so because it
creates it is a it creates absence of
hierarchy or it tries to dissenter right
it tries to remove the pillar so that
everything falls down so yes I think
that it's a good image of the world
post-modernism as a flood so how do so
Gerry Kay asks how does an Orthodox
Christian convert shame and anxiety into
closeness to God
I mean my answer is going to be very
boring and not boring it's just I'm not
going to tell you anything that other
people haven't said it's it's terms of
shame it's it's confession that's the
best way because if you confess then you
you're you are actually submitting
yourself also you're you're giving up to
God but you're also accepting to
humiliate yourself when you go to
confession you humiliate yourself to
your spiritual father
and in that spiritual father if he's
good spiritual father will then give you
a key you know to move on and to to come
back into communion with God so that is
the way to convert shame and and anxiety
then I would say it's prayer for sure
you know Jesus Prayer it's the best in
terms of anxiety because it's it's a
stable one of the things it does it
stabilize you'd save lives your psyche
it stabilizes your thoughts and I say
this like I don't I'm not able to do all
the time I could fall into anxiety to it
but I know that in the moment that I'm
able to to focus on the Jesus Prayer
then you know then usually I find some
kind of peace
all right so Dionysius asks Allah
doesn't in a story the difference
between the figurative and the actual is
clear hmm I'm not sure about that but
let's keep going but in religion the
line between the two is blurred how can
we as a culture we discover the symbolic
worldview will at the same time make
sure that we don't fall back into
superstition assuming that you don't
deny the reality of superstitious
thoughts the superstitious thought could
you articulate and clarify its
distinction from healthy religious
practice
all right so I'm not sure what you mean
by superstition but let me maybe try to
guess I would say that superstitious
superstitious symbolism usually what it
has in it is it is a kind of magical
desire to control events and so it's
using symbolic patterns using symbolic
actions using symbolism to control
phenomena around you so maybe maybe that
would be superstitious there's a lot of
things that people have considered
superstitious which are not at all
superstitious you know I did a whole
video on the evil eye I don't I don't a
lot of people would say that
superstitious I don't think it's
superstitious so maybe it's because I'm
not totally sure I think that I think
that there's causality of meaning and
and a lot of times the reason why we say
superstitious because often it's like
uneducated people end up having these
these causalities of meanings so they
they identify meaning with causality in
the world and I think that sometimes the
problem is that you know they understand
it in a kind of naive way almost like a
scientific way like if I do this then
that or if I do this it protects me from
that whereas whereas the the causality
of meaning is more complex it's it's not
it's not the same type of causality so
maybe that's one of the things that
causes superstition but it's interesting
it's really actually very can be very
fascinating to study superstition
because superstitions are rarely are
rarely arbitrary
they usually they usually actually
manifest like an interesting pattern
they use because sometimes are very old
and they're kind of they've been
whittled down you know they've been and
sometimes the thing I think about
superstitions which now I'm coming a
little maybe I'm coming a little close
to to what
Retin Weinstein talks about we talk
about metaphorical truth but I think
that maybe sometimes superstitions they
are there to create certain patterns of
being which have other causalities that
are not necessarily I'm not necessarily
limited to the precise thing right so
I've talked about this in terms of
purity laws rare the idea of not mixing
wool and linen for example in a cloth
you'd say well house it is stupid like
what does it matter like what does it
matter that you mix wool and linen in a
piece of cloth that superstitious right
but but my my contention is that if you
have several rules like that which cause
you to intuitively understand that is
the need to preserve distinction between
two types of reality then it's going to
create disciplines in you that will be
related to that and will help you avoid
certain pitfalls of mixing mixing
categories in a way that could be
destructive you know I always say that
our world today could be maybe saved if
a few people had remembered not to mix
wildon linen because it seems like the
problem we have right now is that so
it's just an example to say that I think
that if we look at some specific
superstition sometimes we might find
that they're not as and not as stupid as
what we think but sometimes it's it's a
very indirect I haven't studied it in
detail but I would be careful not to be
too too dismissive
alright so John Cage Tompkins asked
Jonathan my sister and I re reading
through the grills brother together and
we just read the princess on the frog
there's an interesting change between
editions the first edition that Princess
turns of frog and Prince I'm picking him
up and throwing him against the wall
yeah in later editions that changes to a
kiss we're stumped on the significance
of throwing a frog again the wall the
story claims that the princess wants to
kill the Frog yes that's right that's
what she wants to do but as soon as he
transforms she's happy to invite him to
her bed any thoughts
yeah she's killing him that's what she's
doing you know she he's a frog
so he doesn't wanna she doesn't want a
frog she wants a man and so the Frog has
to die you know that's what
transformation is transformation is is
death is always a kind of death and
rebirth and so the fact I mean I always
I can understand why it would be changed
with kiss as well it's just it's kind of
it's kind of horrible to imagine you
know the scene but uh but it actually
probably makes more sense that she that
she kills him because because the the
death is what brings about the
transformation you know I mean think
about it this way look guys I'm sorry
this is this is gonna be unpleasant but
how many times does a man change himself
for the better because he was chained by
a woman it's a lot it's quite a bit I
think one of the one of the at one of
the roles or the aspects of the
relationship between the male and female
is that is that the the women are there
to to kill the the beasts the beastly
aspect of of men and they do it
sometimes in a very unpleasant manner
but nonetheless nonetheless it can work
so Robert Terry says what are the
essential books that you want your
children to read to understand the world
when they are teenagers I would say for
sure I mean I mean the Bible I would I
would really want my kids it's hard
because I feel like you really have to
get at them earlier because once they're
teenagers it's almost impossible to
dictate what they would read but for
sure I would say that as children you
need to just just drown them in in fairy
tales and drown them in and you can you
know kids kids kids have a pretty good
capacity to deal with with complex
stories you know I read them a lot of
Russian fairy tales some wonderful stuff
some Czech fairy tales are really
complex some of the Czech fairy tales
are very very powerful in their cosmic
structure they have
they have like three world and you know
these this transformation from brass
into gold and from lead into gold and
there's there's really really powerful
patterns into it and some of the fairy
tales I would say your kids it would be
good they know the Odyssey even if they
knew some Greek some Greek myths that
you know and then as teenagers it's hard
because the world is so man it's messed
up like I think your teenagers have read
Lord of the Rings and I say that and I'm
really struggling to get my 15 year old
son who I love to finish Lord of the
Rings you read the first two books and
he's like he finds it so boring and I'm
like come on man read Lord of the Rings
so I mean I think things like that or
the Rings there in terms of stories that
would be that would be something that I
think your your kid should definitely
read you know and I think when they're
old enough then things like Arthurian
Arthurian legend and history you know
understanding the stories of Alexander I
really don't see in so much as books as
stories I think kids need to know
certain stories so I tend to tell
stories a lot to my kids all right so
all right so I think I think I'm I think
I'm done with the with the question but
for some reason it's not I think I'm
missing some questions one of the things
too is all right okay yeah so that I did
miss some questions one of the things I
would say that's important for people to
understand also is that I've noticed
that I think some people are sending me
questions by email like sending me
instead of putting them as the comments
in the you need to put the need to put
the questions as comments on the post
that I put up on the different platforms
if you send me emails and stuff they
just get lost I can't I can't keep track
of them so I'm sorry if I miss some
questions that way
all right so I'm just gonna check into
the chats already 10:30 you guys are
really like pulling me to the limits
it's fine it's totally fine I'm getting
better at it I think I'm getting better
it kind of not spending too much time on
each question also not getting too
excited all right let's see all right so
there are a lot of questions I might not
be able to get to get through so all
right let's try this go anyways alright
so so Nate H asks what is the symbolism
of the coronavirus beard ah man I was
just I just always wanted to have a very
long beard and so I don't know why I had
the guts to kind of do it if between
between like January and and March um
and but my wife hated the beard and so I
do I was telling her like oh this is
just just the time just let me do it
once you know and so if I I just cut it
off you know it was fun while it lasted
I enjoyed it
all right so Andrew Johnson asks what is
the meaning of the 12 labors of Hercules
what are they besides mythical strongman
feats I mean that they're mostly about
taming things most of Hercules labors I
don't forget remember all of them but
most of them are about killing monsters
you know cleaning stables doing things
that are about bringing order to chaos
right so just manifesting the rule on
the world and so I would say that that's
what they are really so just Peruvians
ask why does God and his speech to joke
with Leviathan and how does that satisfy
Joe I think it's something to do with
new or renewed creation well it has
something to do with the fact that God
goes all the way to the bottom right
he's like he talks about different
aspects of creation and then he goes to
the end and at the end of creation is
the Leviathan you can imagine the life
and like lying at the bottom of the
ocean right or at the edge of the world
some
like that kind of like the rogue burrows
and so I think that's why he goes all
the way to the end and it's like it's
basically a cosmic monster and and the
you know it's like do you understand
this do you understand that there are
things about this world that are bigger
than you could ever fathom like how can
you understand the beast that manifests
chaos right how can you understand that
so I think that that's why it ends the
speech and that's why Joe was kind of a
bit he's it's like it's he realizes that
he's so small and that that his gripe
against God is loses itself in in like
the cosmic story something like that hey
Jonathan what is the Christian symbolic
view on veganism I think that veganism
is like a weird misunderstood version of
spiritual practice because the months
monks don't eat meat at least in the
Orthodox Church monks eat in theories
I'm sure some longs to do eat meat but
in theory monks are are supposed to eat
vegetables and there is a sense in which
eating vegetables is the purest thing
because it
it's what Adam did in the garden but it
collects what Adam do in the garden but
there's also in the story for example in
the desert and the Exodus you have this
sense that God gives the Israelites
water then he gives them manna and then
they complain and complain the complain
and they finally gives the meat and we
give the meat it's seen like kind of
it's almost like God giving in to their
passions for a little bit right and you
can see that it's probably similar in
the story of Noah because the humans
don't eat meat until they're not
supposed to eat meat until the flood and
then after the flood God allows the
humans to eat meat so it's like so it's
so the idea of not eating much of not
even need and eating only vegetables
kind of just moving in moving up the
mountain right going to something more
pure but it's not a moral question not
in Christianity in the sense of like not
killing animals or whatever and it's
also it's also not expected of laypeople
um so do you so Sasha trubiz school asks
do you think the current what religious
phenomenon is related to rooted in the
sharp decline of mainline Protestantism
in the u.s. yes for sure it's the same
people it's the it's that it's the the
continuation of mainline Protestantism
you know and you can see because it's
fed still by a lot of a lot of those
churches like the Methodists and there's
a there you know the Episcopalians all
of that there it's I mean they they're
so focused on social justice they have
reduced Christianity to social justice
and so it's it's take it's like it's
just a continuation of that probably
gonna do a video next week
or maybe after that I mean making a lot
of videos I probably need to carve a
little bit I want to make another video
on the on the difference between Christ
and Barabbas and I might talk about that
and talk also about Judas and how the
sin of Judas in Scripture because it's
very few interaction with Judas is that
he actually wants to give the money of
the perfume that the woman uses to wash
Christ's feet she's using the she's
using this expensive perfume to worship
Christ and Judas says you should give it
to the poor and so there's something
about that about about this kind of
utilitarian use of the of the of
Christianity
all right so M so M asked hi Jonathan
can you speak about the Cabal and how it
relates to Orthodox also been a gossip
Christiana how relates to orthodoxy so
I've talked about before I like I talked
about how the word Kabbalah is very
complicated because it's just such a big
word it just means mystical Judaism I
guess and there are things in Kabbalah
that are that are definitely not in line
with what Christianity says and there
are things in Kabbalah that are actually
that are coming that come closer like
they're some descriptions that are that
are interesting there are some
traditions that can be interesting
sometimes to help you see things from a
different perspective you know
but it's definitely not related it's not
related and and I think that you'll find
probably in modern science you'll find
warnings to not be seduced by by by this
thing but nonetheless like I said I
don't I don't think I think that there
are some interesting aspects like the
sefirot ik tree I think that in the
semiotic tree there's a there's a
there's like two pillars and the central
pillar and there's the notion of like
two sides and and synthesis at different
levels of the ontological of the
ontological reality and so there are
really interesting things in there but I
would say just be careful because it's
it's also not it's not the Christian
traditions if you're Christian you need
to make sure that your whatever
interests you you find it whether it's
in mythology or whether it's in you know
fairy tales even or other mystical
traditions or whatever it always has to
be it always has to be subjugated to
what you are it has to subjugated to the
doctrine of the church as we subjugated
to your spiritual discipline to your
spiritual father so you have to be
careful because things which if you're a
Christian the things which are outside
can can help you sometimes but they have
to be marginal they have to remain
marginal they can't they can't eat your
central tenants probably that makes
sense so Vesuvius asked dr. Marshall
exfoliated to shiburin on social media
for refusing to protect the Catholic
statues in Kali the bishop said vatican
ii made public space the lady's job huh
doctor cited Saint Leo Baron blocked him
thoughts yeah I'm not getting yeah I'm
not going to get into too political
stuff I mean I'm not gonna get into the
political stuff of the church that's not
happening you know my my interactions
with Bishop Baron and his organization
have been positive and you know I'm sure
we disagree on things but I feel like a
lot of the things that he's doing are
helpful so I don't know about this
particular thing I ride I actually wrote
an article for
word on fire which is actually public if
your if anybody here is subscribe to
word on fire you will have the surprise
of discovering in your mailbox an
article for me which talks about movie
interpretation and narrative and also my
let's say the differences I have a
Jordan Peterson I might try I probably
might read it actually I might read it
online next week or in two weeks or
something I might even have Misha Baron
on at some point we'll see if he has
time and accepts how do you interpret
understand dinosaurs from a Christian
worldview monsters dragons so someone
wrote in another language so sorry I
don't understand so drew McMahon asked
why the idea that kids run the world so
prevalent man drew why are you doing
this to me is there literal I know
that's bad we're truth to it or is it
more a representation of our broken
world
look this is I'd talk about symbolism I
would say if you want to if you want to
understand that stuff read go go to the
WikiLeaks read the Clinton emails you
know and you know follow that trail if
that interest you I would say but don't
get too much caught up in that stuff
because it's not really useful for your
soul but the world is a dark place and
there are dark things and so I think
that now is not if the world isn't a
chaotic is in chaos and the world is
clown and the world is upside-down and
the world is perverted in the world is
completely messed up then it means that
the elites are there first that's how it
works the world
I can never you know the the King
becomes immoral before before his
kingdom falls you know and when the
kingdom is fall has fallen it means that
that the the sin of the King is usually
manifesting so yeah
okay so eighties nostalgia guy asked
what is the symbolism of fasting is it
about purification is it about
sacrificing our own flesh why does God
choose to speak to those who fast yeah I
think it is about purification it's
about it's about leaving the things that
come from the outside and focusing on
that which is inside you know and so you
remove the garments of skin you remove
the outer because when you sew like when
you eat or when you engage in sex when
you when you do things like that then
you are you're kind of giving yourself
out right you you were moving out so you
you're focusing your attention on things
which are coming from the outside
pleasures all that until fasting is a
way to kind of shut off those doors and
then try to enter into the end into the
middle into the center so so it is about
sacrificing our own flesh but you don't
have to see you don't see it in a modern
in like a moral way you don't have to
see it in like you're bad you have
sacrifice your flesh you know it's like
you it's not that it's really about
about moving away from the outside and
kind of let's say casting off the outer
layers and moving in towards the center
so all right all right guys so so from
now on I will only answer questions
about symbolism not gonna answer
question about world conspiracies
all right everybody so man it is 10:00
to 11:00 and so I really appreciate I
really I really enjoy these and I
appreciate everybody thanks to all the
people who are supporting me thanks to
all the people who sent super checks you
know I would say try not to go crazy
guys because it's a crazy time right now
and try to you know try not to get too
caught up in the in the madness you know
and I'm not saying ignore it I'm not
saying ignore the craziness
I'm saying try not to get too caught up
and try to remember that Facebook and
Twitter or not the world and you know
that we still have a responsibility to
take care of our families to love our
neighbors and to to remember God and so
so that's as much a call to you as it is
to me because I'm times feel a bit
stretched you know with everything
that's happening and I feel kind of like
being we're being pulled apart and so
hopefully you have family and people
around you that you can hold on to and
hopefully I mean I know that now I've
just recently received an email from my
priest saying that they're starting to
have church services again and I think
that'll be helpful for a lot of people
and as soon as as as your churches are
having services I would say go to church
you know and start communing with real
people and that will be that'd be good
so thanks everybody and I will see you
guys see you guys again next month bye
bye